(upbeat instrumental pop music
- Nail art is gorgeous but I
am terrified of this challenge.
- I'm gonna kill this
and I will become an internet
Pinterest sensation overnight.
- Most of these designs
are way more complicated
than anyone should have on their nails.
- It looks so easy,
it's just painting your nails.
- This base coat is so
important because if it's not
just really pretty
then you can't paint over it well.
- (cough, cough) Oh, God.
- Oh there's a brush inside.
- It's a lot wetter then I was expecting.
- I'm doing my best not
to get it on my fingers.
My best isn't good enough.
- Makes a nice sound.
- I am fingernail Picasso.
- It's like a horrible
wax museum right now.
- This is something
that would be nice to do
with a glass of wine and some music.
- This I might be able to do
cuz it's like a straight line.
- I guess I'm just gonna glob
it on and see if it dries.
- It's hard to like get enough
but also not get too much.
- Looks kinda like I put a blob
in the middle of my finger.
- Dance for me. Woah it got
everywhere. Oh no, way too much.
- There is zero margin for error here.
- I really have no idea what I'm doing.
- Oh, God, I'm just gonna let that dry.
It's gonna look like a huge bead.
- Okay, not too bad, here's the thing,
like if I was actually doing this,
I would be like think I
finished up this hand and
looked over, I would have (beep sound) up
my other hand completely.
- Ya, I think all hopes of
getting this design right
have gone out the window
like three layer ago.
- Alright, I think that's
as close as I can get.
- Hey Will, what are
you doing after the gym?
Some mother (beep sound) nail art.
- I'm gonna try to do
the leaf marks with this.
It's just like blobbing.
You know what at first this was like funny
I was like ha ha I'm gonna paint my nails
and now I really care and
this is kinda frustrating.
- It doesn't look deliberate.
If someone came up to me
she would just be like "oh."
Not even like congratulations
for even trying.
- It's too easy. I'm doin it.
- Now it looks like there's
a butt cheek on my hand.
- I'm far too fresh for black stripes
I'm gonna go (beep
sound) neon pink stripes.
- I knew I was gonna be crap at it
I didn't realize how crap I'd be.
- Do I like em? I don't know.
And the stripes are
just like why did I go,
why did I go bright pink?
- I think I should probably go back
and probably learn how to
draw within the lines again.
- My other hand got some
nail art of its own.
- And I feel like a was very careful.
- I thought I was a creative person but
I just don't have the
dexterity in my hands
to make something beautiful
on the tiny canvass
that is your fingernail.
- I tried.
- I feel like I'm supposed
to be holding something
but I'm painting my own hand.